Здравствуйте, уважаемые участники Хакатона. Меня зовут Данил. Сегодня немного поговорим про базовые технологии, которые могут быть вам полезны при выполнении задач Хакатона.
В втором треке, отчасти в первом, вам придется строить свои собственные модели, суррогатные модели временных рядов, агентов, принимающих решения.
И для этого нужна некая такая общая база, какая-то математика, на которой все это строится, некоторую архитектуру рассмотрим,
которые сегодня применяются для обработки временных рядов.
И понимание того, как эти модели встраиваются в мультиагентные системы и в обучении с покреплением.
Сегодняшняя лекция – это как раз по такой некую базовый обзор возможных технологий, которые вы можете применять.
Основная цель лекции – это дать вам некий словарь, инструментарий и понимание того, как эти технологии работают внутри.
И только дальше вы сами осознанно спроектировали решение под свой трек.
Прежде чем пробежаться, быстро пройдемся по карте того, что нас ждет.
8 разделов. Начнем с введения, разберем, что такое вообще deep learning, как метод, как работает самая простая нейросеть.
Вот там линейные регрессии до грезентного спуска и функции активации.
Немножко введем формализацию.
Второй раздел – это путь от рекуррентных сетей, LSTM, и к трансформерам, уже к более современным моделям.
Третий раздел – это интерпретируемость, что можно, что нельзя понять, заглянув внутрь модели через механизм внимания.
И дальше начинаем более уже такая прикладная часть, ближе к задаче.
Это суррогатные модели, reinforcement learning, обучение с подкреплением, дальше мультиагентные системы.
И в конце соберу какие-то общие такие итоги.
Так, зачем вообще нужен deep learning?
И есть огромный класс задач, которые мы прекрасно умеем формулировать человеческим языком,
но которые совершенно не умеем описывать математической формулой или алгоритмом.
Что такое кошка на фотографии?
Непонятно, как объяснить компьютеру правила, как он будет отличать кошку от собаки.
И такие вот существуют трудноформализованные задачи.
Это вот называется семантическим разрывом.
То же самое с детектированием объектов похода, с переводом машинным, с генерацией звука.
Есть, конечно, существуют всякие эвристики, можно писать правила, признаки.
Но вот deep learning, как технология глубокого обучения, предлагает несколько иной путь.
Вместо того, чтобы вручную писать правила, мы строим черный ящик и показываем там тысячи примеров,
и он сам находит закономерности, которые мы не смогли сформулировать явно.
Далее, давайте немножко формализуем это все.
Черный ящик – это, по сути, функция, которая отображает некий х в у от звездочек со звездочкой,
и х – это входные данные, и у – это предсказанные выходные.
Данные, в общем-то, неважно, что это за данные.
Это могут быть картинки, звук, видео или какие-то временные ряды со скважин.
В конце концов, все сводится к числам, векторам и матрицам многомерным.
Изображение – это просто матрица, ширина на высота и, допустим, три канала на цвет,
если мы говорим про цветное изображение.
Аудиосигнал тоже – это лектор отсчетов.
Видео более многомерная уже вещь.
Может быть, время, какая-то ширина, высота, каналы цветовые и так далее.
И для нашей задачи тоже применимо.
Показание датчика скважин во времени – это тоже просто вектор или матрица чисел, которые подаются в модель.
При этом модель не знает и не должна знать, кто перед ней.
Физика, она видит просто числа.
Как именно вообще черный ящик получает свой ответ?
Фундаментально идти глубокого обучения – искать связи между элементами,
входа и выхода.
Самый простой пример, с которого стоит начать – это многомерная линейная регрессия,
когда просто у нас f со звездочкой от x – это β1x плюс β2.
И мы, по сути, тут уже получаем такой самый простой строительный блок любой нейросети –
это линейный слой.
и метод, получается, вычисляет выходные значения через различные связи между входом и элементами вектора параметров.
Дальше.
Признаки – это то, из чего состоит, собственно, входной вектор x.
Для изображения признаками могут быть цветовые каналы,
или контуры, границы объектов.
Для сигнала могут быть сами отчеты,
или каким-то образом они нормализованы могут быть.
Здесь есть важная развилка.
Признаки можно конструировать вручную,
и это так называемый фича инжиниринг,
конструирование признаков,
а можно доверить самой нейросети.
И на картинке справа
классические примеры, сконструированные вручную признаку –
это контуры объектов на фотографии,
или три цветовых канала цветного изображения.
нейросети в значительной степени избавились от этой ручной работы,
но, добегая вперед, для суррогатных моделей,
о которых мы потом еще поговорим,
вопрос, какие признаки подавать на вход,
все равно остается крайне важным.
Начнем с нашей простой модели.
f от x, вот это равно β1x плюс β2.
Как вообще такую штуку обучать?
Обучение – это подбор таких параметров,
которые минимизируют функцию ошибки.
Тут она названа L.
Между предсказанием модели и настоящим ответом Y.
Тут возникает закономерный вопрос,
как вообще найти минимум этой функции,
и, в общем-то, делается это просто градиентным спуском
или одной из модификаций этого метода.
Шаги спуска – это понятная вещь.
Сначала у нас некие начальные параметры.
Мы вычисляем градиент ошибки на катом шаге,
после чего спускаемся, обновляем параметры
и снова вычисляем функцию ошибки.
Но у такой модели, как мы рассматривали, у простой,
все еще остается существенная проблема.
Дело в том, что она линейна,
соответственно, какие-то сложные нелинейные зависимости,
таким бы большим мы не выбрали датасет,
такая модель предсказывать не может.
И для этого вводится функция активации.
Она добавляется сразу после линейной комбинации входа
и создает нелинейность,
которой вот этому линейному слову
изначально не хватало.
Самая такая классическая функция активации – это сигмольда.
Есть также гиперболические тангенсы,
релу, лики релу,
которые чуть лучше в плане того,
что он в отрицательной нелинейности
не просто в ноль отображает,
а вот в некую такую пологую тоже прямую.
И также важной такой функцией является softmax.
Она обычно применяется на выходе классификаторов
и по сути отображает нам некий выход слоя
в вероятности каждого признака.
Итого у нас уже есть линейный слой плюс функция активации.
Это уже полноценная однослойная и нелинейная модель,
в которой уже можно работать.
Если собрать подряд несколько таких линейных слоев,
мы получим простейший многослойный перцептрон.
Этот перцептрон, наверное, не очень правильный термин,
все-таки классический перцептрон розенблата –
это несколько иная вещь.
минус такого подхода, именно работы с линейными слоями –
это то, что он не учитывает порядок элементов на входе.
То есть это критично для работы, опять же, с временными рядами,
с сигналами, с последовательностями, где нам важен порядок.
И обучается многослойный перцептрон,
тем же градиентным спуском, но градиент тут считается сразу по всем слоям.
Для этого существует функция обратного распространения ошибки.
На практике это все выполняют фреймворки автоматически,
PyTorch или TensorFlow, в зависимости от того, что вы выбираете,
что вам больше нравится.
Кто хочет подробнее в это погрузиться, в списке литературы будут ссылки.
Отдельный важный такой момент – это контроль качества модели.
То есть мы что-то обучили, а как у нас вообще эта модель будет потом работать на практике.
Для этого разделяют выборку всю, которая у нас есть,
на тренировочно-эваляционную тестовую.
На тренировочную производится расчет функций ошибки и, собственно, сам градиентный спуск.
Модель напрямую подгоняет эти данные.
Также есть выборка эваляционная.
Она из того же распределения обычно берется, из того же датасета,
но не участвует в спуске, используется именно для, может быть, выбора гиперпараметров,
для контроля того, как модель обучается и какая у нее обобщающая способность.
И, наконец, тестовая выборка.
Это отдельная выборка, которая не используется в обучении вовсе.
И это такая финальная, не привязаться, это оценка качества.
И наилучшим вообще вариантом выбора тестового датасета – это вообще другой датасет.
Как-то отдельно собранный.
Или максимально отделенный от изначально.
И, соответственно, по соотношению графика именно train-emolitation происходит диагностика недо- или переобучения.
И тест – это уже как финальные метрики того, что у нас получилось.
Тут есть важный момент.
Это утечки данных между выборками.
Нужно грамотно разбивать тренировочно-еволюционную тесты в выборке.
При этом важно, чтобы данные в выборках были перемешаны и между выборками.
Но есть опасность такая, как, например, во время аугментации.
Аугментация должна быть расширение искусственного датасета.
То есть, например, если мы говорим про изображение, это может быть поворот, линейный сдвиг, какие-то растяжения изображения.
И важно ее выполнять уже после разбиения на выборке.
Иначе измененные копии одного и того же объекта могут быть в разной выборке.
Это называется, собственно, утечкой данных.
Когда у нас одни и те же данные попадают в разные выборки.
И итоговая оценка может оказаться завышенной и нерелевантной.
Собственно, как понять по графикам, что у нас происходит с сетью.
Слева у нас на картинке это классический такой признак.
Классическая картина недообучения.
Когда обе у нас кривые и тренировочная, и эволюционная, держатся на высоком значении ошибки и почти не улучшается.
Модель слишком простая или недообученная.
Ну, бывает и обратная ситуация, когда модель слишком сложная, у нас не хватает данных для того, чтобы ее обучить.
Следующая картинка это переобучение.
Когда у нас на тренировочной выборке продолжает ошибка падать, а эволюционная начинает расти в какой-то момент.
Это говорит о том, что модель просто нас запомнила всю нашу тренировочную выборку.
Если у нее достаточно параметров, она вполне может это сделать.
И таким образом она просто выучивает эти элементы, и никакой общающей способности там нет.
И в таком случае у нас на валидации будет расти ошибка.
И, в общем-то, такое хорошее обучение, когда у нас обе выборки падают, и тренировочная, и эволюционная.
Обычно на эволюционную ошибку чуть выше, то, естественно.
Но могут быть нюансы с тем, как мы усредняем ошибку.
То есть бывает такое, что эволюционная проходит чуть ниже.
При этом они оба выходят на некое плато.
Вот. Картинки чисто для примера.
Это не из какого-то конкретного эксперимента.
И такой завершаем модный блок.
Классификация задач, которая решает глубокое обучение.
Это обучение с учителем, когда у нас на вход есть х, и ожидаемый отхлепь у.
Это различные задачи классификации, регрессии, ранжирования, сегментации.
И это достаточно большой класс задач.
И второй класс задач — это обучение без учителя,
когда у нас нет какого-то размеченного датасета.
Но при этом обучение тоже можно таким образом построить,
например, с помощью восстановления замаскированных последовательностей.
И обычно это используют для устранения шумов,
для обучения представления,
которое потом уже можно использовать для других задач.
Далее переходим к разделу уже про архитектуры.
Рекуррентная сеть RNN — это сеть,
которая предназначена для последовательной обработки информации.
Допустим, есть у нас некая последовательность сигналов,
слов в тексте, с датчиков, с кироскопа, давления на скважине.
Как такую информацию обрабатывать?
Ну, собственно, последовательно.
Ответ довольно банальный.
Применяя одну и ту же функцию каждому элементу,
передавая шаг через скрытое состояние.
Как конкретно это работает?
Вот у нас схема.
Одна и та же функция А применяется к входу к очередному элементу последовательности XN,
и получаем HN.
И при этом мы еще передаем сам результат этой сети в следующий шаг.
Но вот в такой самой простой схеме есть проблема,
что когда у нас длинная последовательность,
у нас вся эта информация довольно плохо передается от, скажем, там,
X0 к какому-нибудь X100.
Она просто затухнет.
Таким образом, нам нужен некий механизм памяти,
когда у нас сеть будет запоминать хоть немножко,
что было на предыдущем шаге.
Для этого применяется, например, архитектура LST,
долгая и кредкосрочная память.
Механизм памяти вот тут управляет забыванием и обновлением.
У нее есть три гейта, так называемых.
Это input, что...
И запомнить.
Gate, что забыть.
И output, что, собственно, отдать наружу.
Плюс отдельное ячейко состояние.
Вот это вот CT.
Gate.
Gate – это обычные линейные слои с сегмоидами и гиперболическими тангенсами
в качестве функции активации.
Обучаются градиентным спускам вместе со всей сетью.
Но тут тоже у них есть некоторые ограничения у таких сетей.
Другой вариант – это GRU.
Такая более легкая альтернатива LST.
Когда у нас вместо двух кейтов между различными элементами последовательности
один, точнее, тут еще выходной.
В смысле трех, два.
И нет отдельной у нас вот этой ячейкой памяти.
Просто некое состояние, вот это reset, сброс и обновление.
На практике часто оказывается, что не хуже ничем, чем LST,
но она меньше по параметрам, компактнее модель получается и дешевле по вычислениям.
Но у них есть существенные проблемы.
Несмотря на то, что в LST, в GRU есть механизмы для того,
чтобы запоминать элементы последовательности на действительно длинных последовательностях,
они справляются уже с трудом.
поэтому тут нужно что-то более совершенное.
И еще одна проблема является распараллеливание.
Поскольку данные обрабатываются шаг за шагом,
это делает RNN довольно трудным в распараллеливании,
что ограничивает применение GPU для современных задач.
При том, что получается, чтобы, например, вычислить градиент,
у нас получается вложенная такая функция на каком-то там сотом шаге,
сто раз друг к другу вложено.
Это все нужно развернуть по всей сети, посчитать градиент для того,
чтобы сделать один шаг.
И отсюда у нас вытекает проблема с временем обучения.
То есть из-за того, что данные обрабатывают последовательно,
следовательно, не так хорошо эти сети распараллеливаются,
как, допустим, перцептроны,
где-то перемножать матрицы,
GPU с этим прекрасно справляется,
требуется значительно больше времени,
особенно на каких-то больших, значительных наборах данных.
И здесь возникает механизм внимания.
То есть вместо жесткой какой-то рекуррентности
мы получаем прямой доступ к любому элементу последовательности.
И тут некая такая идея, сравнимая с идеей базы данных.
У нас есть запрос, ключ, с чем мы сравниваем запрос,
и value – это значение, которое возвращает эти совпадения хорошие.
Отправляем запрос, получаем ответ в виде взвешенной суммы.
Значение интерес пропорционально тому,
насколько запрос похож на каждый ключ.
Это достаточно простая функция.
У нас кьюри и кейс сначала перемножаются,
после чего используется масштабирование,
которое на самом деле призвано просто улучшить сходимость сети,
чтобы не было взрывов или затуханий градиентов.
После чего вычисляется функция активации softmax.
Это, в общем-то, простая, на самом деле,
все внимание – это просто функция,
в которой нет каких-то обучающих параметров.
Там сразу на вход подается и запрос, и ключ, и значение.
И просто это такая специальная функция,
которая нам возвращает взвешенную сумму.
И затем это, собственно, перемножается на в.
Используется семейство таких seconds to seconds,
RNN с attention,
и как основа для архитектуры трансформера.
Вот тут пример с рекуррентной сетью.
Когда мы...
Классический секунст to seconds.
Мы работаем с машинным переводом тут.
Нам нужно перевести вот некую фразу.
Здесь применяется архитектура энкодер-декодер,
когда энкодер последовательно строит представление для каждого слова,
а декодер генерирует каждое слово перевода,
взвешенно подсматривающего состояния энкодера
с помощью функции внимания,
и таким образом генерируя ответ.
И справа тут такие классические варианты attention.
Вот product, который мы уже рассматривали,
билинейный,
и это может быть даже какая-то обучающая функция
в качестве email.
И выбор конкретной реализации,
это уже зависит от архитектуры.
Далее появилась уже в 2017 году
статья буквально, которая называется
«Внимание – это все, что вам нужно»,
когда вся архитектура сразу строится вокруг внимания.
И это архитектура трансформера.
В энкодере используется self-attention,
когда токены смотрят друг на друга,
и там буквально в качестве всех трех
этих входов функции
кьюри-кьюри-вэлю применяется
одна и та же информация.
И мы получаем,
насколько токены соотносятся друг с дружкой
в одной этой большой последовательности.
В декодере используется
еще дополнительное маскирование
внутри внимания,
для того, чтобы токены смотрели
только на предыдущие токены,
когда мы генерируем, допустим, перевод.
И плюс есть некий такой cross-attention
в декодере-энкодере,
именно в декодере,
который запрос соотносит
состояние декодера
и ключи значения из энкодера.
И плюс тут применяются
такие всякие хитрости,
вроде feedforward network
и residual connection,
достаточные связи,
которые просто прибавляют вход
обратно к выходу слоя,
и получается, что у нас очередной слой
не полностью изменяет данные,
не полностью их трансформирует,
а именно добавляет превращение,
что, в общем-то,
достаточно хорошо соотносится
с идеей градиентного спуска
и таким образом улучшается сходимость
на больших глубоких сетях
с большим количеством слоев.
и после внимания
только на этот момент
подумать.
Дальше, как, собственно,
помимо самого attention,
существует
и применяется в трансформерах
multi-head attention.
здесь сначала
входные данные
проецируются
в пространстве
меньшей размерности
с помощью
линейного
уже обучающегося слоя,
и как раз вот эти вот
проекции являются
обучаемыми,
то, как именно нужно
проецировать,
и для каждой
такой головы,
так называемой,
куда данные у нас
проецировались,
вычисляется функция
внимания,
после чего
данные
конкатинируются,
и снова
проходят
линейный слой.
Также важным моментом
является
использование
позиционного
кодирования
в сетях
такого рода,
поскольку
данные
теперь мы
обрабатываем
снова параллельно,
как изначально
было у нас
в перцептроне,
соответственно,
нам нужно
добавить
информацию
о том,
в каком порядке
у нас идут
элементы последовательных.
для этого
существует
множество
различных функций
позиционного
кодирования,
поскольку
само внимание
эту позицию
не учитывает
и не может
учитывать,
там
все со всеми
взаимодействуют.
И
здесь у нас
полная схема,
такая сводная,
все архитектуры
целиком,
чтобы увидеть,
как все собирается
вместе.
Одные
эмбеддинги,
к ней
добавляют
позиционное
кодирование,
несколько
слоев
энкодера
с
multi-head
attention,
с residual
connection,
с сетью
прямого
распространения,
где у нас
еще дополнительные
есть веса.
Это, по сути,
тоже
двуслойный
такой
перцептрон.
И
декодер,
в который
поступает
предыдущий
выход
модели,
через
него
вычисляется
уже маскированный
multi-head attention
через
на этой информации,
после чего
вычисляется
некий
cross-attention
между
декодером
и
энкодером,
и снова
сеть
прямого
распространения.
Причем у нас
подряд таких
N-блоков
стоит
внутри
сети.
От
оригинального
трансформера
2017 года,
в общем-то,
прошло
достаточно много
времени,
и
современные
языковые
модели,
таких как
GPT,
Lama,
Mistral,
DFC,
QN,
все что угодно,
фундамент
остается тем же
самым,
все еще применяет
self-attention,
multi-head attention,
традиционное
кодирование,
это все остается,
имеются
некоторые только
детали уже
инженерной
реализации.
Появились
оптимизированные
функции
внимания сначала,
это
flash attention,
который
быстрее
экономнее
по памяти,
multi-
или
групп
QN,
которые
требуют
меньше
кива и кэша,
sparse linear
attention
для
длинных
последовательностей,
разреженное
внимание,
а не
полное.
Современный
уже такой
тренд,
это
mixture of
factor,
смесь экспертов,
когда вместо
одного большого
фидфорвард
слоя,
двуслойного
перцептрона,
у нас
несколько
поменьше,
набор
экспертов,
из которых
на каждый
токен
активируется
только часть,
и в частности
используют
mix trial,
dpc
kmoe,
в kwenye
это тоже
применяется,
и
вывод
можно сделать,
что детали
конкретных
продуктов
архитектуры
эволюционируют,
но
именно
базов
в виде
self-attention
и позиционного
кодирования
остается
прежней.
Теперь
поговорим
немножко
про
интерпретируемость.
Это тоже
важная
такая
задача
в треках,
чтобы
можно было
объяснить
результаты
модели.
Один из
таких
практических
много
счастливых
побочных
эффектов
внимания
является то,
что веса
внимания
можно посмотреть
и оценить,
на что
модель
конкретно
обращает
свое
внимание
и как
она
принимает
решение.
В отличие
от,
например,
RNN
или
MLP,
здесь
скрытые
представления
гораздо
труднее
интерпретировать
напрямую.
Зачем
вообще
нам
интерпретируемость?
Тут
несколько
причин.
Это
может быть
отладка
модели,
чтобы понять,
почему она
ошибается.
Это
доверие
к предсказаниям,
особенно важно,
если решение
модели
влияет
на реальные
действия,
вашей
задачи.
Поиск
скрытых
ошибок
или
утечек
данных,
когда модель
подсматривает
не туда,
куда нужно,
и,
наконец,
это
некая
объяснимость
вообще
того,
как
работает
модель.
Конкретный
такой
пример
с
энкодера
трансформера
с 5 и 6
слоя,
в общем-то,
из оригинальной
статьи,
взята
картинка,
как,
например,
сеть
связывает
глагол
making
с другими
словами
предложений,
какие головы
обращают
внимание
на
какие слова.
изначально
идея голов
заключается в том,
что у нас,
допустим,
одна голова
будет смотреть
на
какие-то
семантические
признаки,
другая на
лексические,
третья
еще на
что-то,
и
вот так
будут распределены
некие задачи.
на практике,
конечно,
так четко
они не разделяются,
но,
тем не менее,
часто получается так,
что головы
работают
чуть-чуть
по-разному,
и,
в конечном счете,
это улучшает
результат модели.
Ну,
собственно,
вот про разные роли,
что тут показано,
как разные головы
по-разному
вообще связывают
между собой
слова-предложения.
и
тут вывод
такой,
что
внимание модели
это не какая-то там
одна карта
такая большая,
а набор
специализированных карт
под каждую голову
и более того,
под каждый слой,
поскольку
функция внимания
применяется
не единожды
по ходу прохождения
данных
через модель.
Тут у нас
возникает проблема,
что если у нас
есть глубокое,
функций внимания
много,
ни один слой,
несколько подряд,
много голов,
как вообще
это все оценить.
Внимание
на одной конкретной
голове,
на одном конкретном
слое,
это только часть
общей картины,
а глубокие сети
информации
проходят через
много слоев.
Существует метод
attention rollout,
метод,
который решает
именно эту задачу,
агрегирует
веса внимания
по всем словам
сразу,
получает итоговую
такую карту
внимания,
как в итоге
каждый входной
токен
влияет на
финальный результат
с учетом
всего пути
через сеть.
Идея реализации
достаточно простая,
это последовательно
просто перемножить
матрицы внимания
слоев,
учитывая при этом
остаточные
резидуио связи,
накапливая
вот таким образом
вход,
вклад
каждого входного
элемента.
И, в общем-то,
достаточно часто
применяется
для работы
с последовательностями
с помощью
архитектурных
трансформеров.
Но
attention map
это все еще
карта внимания,
которая просто
является
матрицей
вот этих
весов
внимания
между токенами
и позициями.
Она обычно
визуализируется
как
плавая карта,
полезна для
отладки,
где модель
конкретно
концентрируется
на каких признаках,
есть ли какие-то
осмысленные
паттерны в ней.
Но
тут важная
оговорка.
Внимание
не равно
объяснению.
Сейчас в литературе
идет прямая
дискуссия на эту
тему.
Сырые
веса
внимания
не всегда
причина связана
с итоговым решением
модели.
Это
стоит
к ним
относиться
как к
февристике,
а не
к строгому
доказательству.
отдельная
актуальная
тема
цепочки
рассуждений,
когда модель
проговаривает
промежуточные
шаги
рассуждения
перед финальным
ответом,
что дает
человек
отчитаемое
объяснение
кода решения.
Из плюсов
заметно повышает
качество на
сложных
пошаговых
задачах,
проверит
логику по
шагам,
но
вербализация
рассуждений
не гарантирует
то, что
модель
на самом
деле
вычислила
внутри.
И
рассуждение
может
выглядеть
красивым,
но
достоверно
не отражающим
реальный
внутренний
процесс.
И
такой
главный
вывод,
что
универсального
какого-то
метода
на все
случаи
жизни,
даже для
трансформеров,
по тому,
как интерпретировать
результаты работы
моделей,
не существует.
И
для каждой
конкретной
архитектуры,
для каждой
конкретной
модели
нужно подбирать
что-то
свое.
для
сверточных
сетей,
это тоже
там
карты
активации
существуют,
для
RNN,
LSTM,
это
анализ
критого
состояния,
плата
отдельных
шагов
последовательных,
можно
отслеживать
буквально
по слоям,
как
классификатор
разделяет
постепенно
выборки.
Трансформеры
ELM,
это
мапы,
rollout,
различные
классификаторы,
цепочки
рассуждений,
и тут
практический
вывод,
что выбирая
архитектуру
для будущих
ваших
суррогатных
моделей,
сразу закладывайте,
как вы будете
их интерпретировать,
насколько это
важный
аспект.
Теперь
следующий
раздел,
что такое
суррогатные
модели,
максимально
близкий,
практический
для вас
раздел.
Суррогатная
модель,
иногда еще
называют
метамодель
или эмулятор,
это
быстрая
аппроксимация
дорогого
источника
истины,
как физической
симуляции
или реального
эксперимента.
Строится
она по
ограниченному
набору
дорогих
прогонов
симулятора
и
учится
предсказывать
его выход
на входные
параметры,
но при этом
работает в разы,
часто
на порядке
быстрее.
Отсюда
понятно,
зачем это
нужно.
Один точный
расчет
физического
симулятора
может
занимать
часы,
дни,
и
получается,
что для
перебора
тысячи
сценариев,
для
оптимизации
или для
анализа
неопределенности,
для быстрого
принятия
решения
это
не
подходит.
Таким
образом
строится
некая
суррогатная
модель,
которая
может
быстро
решать.
И
внизу
некая
диаграмма
у меня
физический
симулятор,
который
долго считается.
Собираем
данные,
обучаем
этих данных
суррогатную
модель
и получаем
достаточно
быстрые
прогнозы.
Да,
с погрешностями,
но
зато
гораздо
быстрее.
Тут
важно,
почему это
особенно
применимо
к вашим
трекам.
Симулятор
пласта
достаточно
сложная
вычислительная
задача.
соответственно,
из-за
этого
возникает
требование
в отрасли
для
прокси-моделей
изначально
и
современные
уже
LST
трансформеры.
Суррогат
особенно
оправдан
там,
где решение
принимается
многократно,
быстро,
и оптимизация
режима работы
скважин
отличная
для того
применения.
как теперь
конкретный
временной ряд
становится
суррогатной
моделью.
Идея
простая,
вместо
полного
физического
расчета
LSTM
или
трансформер,
какая-то
другая
архитектура
предсказывает
динамику
интересующего
нас показателя
по входным
управляющим
параметрам.
Это уже
проверенный
подход
на практике
и
встречается
в литературе
достаточно часто.
Есть
другой
прием,
это
предобучение
на дешевых
грубых сетках
и обучение
на малом числе
дорогих
детальных
прогонов.
То есть
уже
в сторону
трансфреленок
и
с
различными
данными.
Сначала
просто
делаем
какую-то
такую
грубую
модель
и дальше
уже
ее
дообучаем
более
конкретно.
Откуда
вообще
берутся
данные
для
суррогата?
Это
принципиально
отличает
задачи
от
привычных
ML-задач.
Обычно
данные
уже даны
заранее,
кем-то
собраны,
профифицированы
может быть
даже.
Здесь
не так.
Данные
для
суррогата
нужно
специально
сгенерировать
и запускать
дорогой
эксперимент,
фигический
симулятор
и заранее
выбранных
точках
пространства
входных
параметров.
И
здесь
целая
дисциплина
дизайновый
эксперимент.
И
один из
аспектов,
какую
сетку
выбрать.
бывает
равномерная
сетка
или
случайная
выборка,
или
специальная
letting
supercube
sampling,
которая
специально
сконструирована
таким образом,
чтобы гарантировать,
что по каждому
измерению
пространства
параметров
точки
распределены
равномерно.
То есть
именно
в каждом
отдельном
измерении
признаков.
и в итоге
покрытие
получается
заметно
лучше,
чем при
каких-то
других подходах.
очевидно,
чем лучше
у нас покрытие,
чем оно
равномернее,
тем проще
модели
обучиться.
В том
смысле,
что
нет
каких-то
неопределенностей,
и мы
не будем
требовать
от модели
некой
экстраполяции,
которая
может
плохо
закончиться.
отдельный
направление,
физически
обусловленный
подход.
Вот.
Когда
у нас
в
сеть
она
одновременно
обучается
подгонять
данные
под физику,
и
функцию
ошибки
уже
закладывается
здесь
физика.
есть
более
легкие
альтернативы,
когда модель
предсказывает
не
сырой
результат,
а поправку
к упрощенной
физической
модели,
и она
берет
лучшие
подходы
чистого
ML и
PIN,
так называемого.
главный
подводный
камень
суррогатного
моделирования,
которым нужно
помнить
постоянно,
это
риск
экстраполяции.
Суррогат
опущен
на
конечном
ограниченном
диапазоне
входных
параметров,
и за
его
пределами
прогноз
не
гарантирован.
и на графике
справа
это показано
наглядно,
когда у нас
истинная
физика,
симулятор
начинает
расходиться
с суррогатной
моделью
в зоне
экстраполяции.
Поэтому
перед использованием
суррогата
для оптимизации
проверяйте,
не выходят
ли предложенные
решения
за диапазон
обучающих
данных.
другие
подводные
камни,
которые стоит
держать
в уме,
это
переобучение
под артефакты
симулятора.
Суррогат
в принципе
может
выучить
не саму
физику,
а особенности
конкретной
численной
схемы
того
симулятора,
на прогонах
которого он
обучался.
И тогда
он не
будет
точнее
того,
на чем
обучен.
И
в некоторых
всем
плохих
случаях
будет даже
воспроизводить
специфические
численные
погрешности
того метода,
на котором
он обучался.
Второе
это физическая
правдоподобность.
Прогнозы
суррогата
могут
нарушать
законы
сохранения
или
монотонности,
что тоже
может быть
критично.
И стоит
закладывать
такие проверки
на такие
нарушения.
Может быть
какие-то
штрафы,
функции
потери,
ошибки.
и
третий
момент
это
оценка
неопределенности.
Хорошая
суррогатная
модель
не только
предсказывает
какие-то
значения,
но и
в каком-то
смысле
понимает,
насколько
он уверен
в этом
прогнозе.
Особенно
важно
ближе
к границам
обучающего
диапазона.
Дальше
поговорим
пятый уже
раздел
reinforcement learning
обучение
с подкреплением.
Это
достаточно
широкая
область.
Тут
все
достаточно
компактно
в разделе.
Логика
какая?
Агент
у нас
существует
специальный
агент,
который
взаимодействует
со средой.
И
на каждом
шаге
он наблюдает
состояние
S,
выбирая
действия,
а
состояние
своей
политикой
и
получает
награду
R
и переходит
в новое
состояние.
Некая
такая
формальная
математическая
рамка
это
маркерский
процесс
принятия
решений.
Когда у
нас
она включает
состояние
действия
вероятности
перехода
между
состояниями
награды,
коэффициент,
сконтирование
гаммы,
который
дает баланс
между
немедленной
и долгосрочной
выгодкой.
Грубо говоря,
насколько
агент
нетерпелив.
Ключевые
отличия от
привычного
нам
Superwise Learning
потому,
что здесь
нет
разметки
правильных
ответов.
Обучение
идет методом
проб и ошибок
ориентируясь
на сигнал
наград,
причем
этот сигнал
часто
отложен
во времени
и разрежен.
То есть
происходит
нечасто
и не сразу
после действия,
которое
ему привело.
И на диаграмме
такая классическая
схема
взаимодействия
агента
со средой.
Кратко
пройдемся
по основным
семействам
методов
Reinformation Learning.
буквально
на уровне
ориентировки
не было
какие-то
детали.
Существуют
Value Based
методы,
например,
Cool Learning
или его
нейросетивый вариант
DQNN,
Deep
Network.
Модель
учит оценку
ценностей
каждого действия
в каждом
состоянии,
а затем
действует,
просто выбирая
действия
с лучшей
оценкой.
Policy Based
или Policy
Gradient
методы,
например,
очень популярный
сегодня
Proximal
Policy
Optimization,
модель
напрямую
учит саму
политику,
то есть
отображение
и состояние
в действии
без промежуточной
оценки
ценностей.
Такие методы
обычно более устойчивы,
там,
где управляющие
параметры
непрерывны.
И еще
одна важная
развилка
это
Model Free
и Model Based.
методы
учатся
исключительно
на непосредственном
взаимодействии
со средой,
а Model Based
использует
явную
или самостоятельно
выученную
модель
динамики
среды,
чтобы заранее
планировать действия,
не проверяя
каждый вариант
на практике.
Дальше.
Теперь
почему
это
напрямую
относится
к вашей
задаче.
Управление
скважинами
пластом
это,
по сути,
свое
последовательное
принятие
решений.
Настройки,
темп закачки,
режим добычи
меняются
раз за разом
на протяжении
всей жизни
месторождения,
чтобы
максимализировать
необходимые
нам параметры.
И это
прямо
и естественно
ложится
в рамки
MDP,
о которой
только что
говорили.
Это
есть
уже
конкретные
опубликованные
результаты
того,
как,
например,
на основе
PPO
управляли
разработкой
месторождения
в замкнутом цикле
и добили
даже
некого
прироста
показателя,
при этом
на 76%
сократив
требования
к прогону
симулятора,
чем в традиционном
подходе.
и
также
те же
авторы
показали,
что
можно
обучить
одну
общую
политику
сразу
для
нескольких
активов
одновременно,
и это
три раза
ускоряет
обучение.
Но
важный момент,
я вам не предлагаю
взять какую-то
конкретную
архитектуру,
просто
показываю,
что
задача
класса управления
режимом во времени
типична
для методов
RL,
и
в литературе
уже есть
проверенные
ориентиры.
Здесь
мы
замыкаем
связь
с предыдущим
разделом
лекции,
RL и
суррогатные
модели
работают
вместе.
Дело
в том,
что RL
обычно требует
огромного
числа
взаимодействия
со средой,
тысяча
частых
миллионов
эпизодов.
Тренировать
агента
прямо на
полном
физическом
симуляторе,
который
считается
часы
один
прогон
просто нереально
по времени,
поэтому
суррогатная
модель
из раздела
4 часто
выступает
в роли
быстрой
среды
для обучения
уже RL
агента.
Агент
учится
взаимодействовать
не с
симулятором,
а именно
с суррогатом.
И на
диаграмме
внизу
та же
самая
логика
взаимодействия
с суррогатом,
но уже
не со
средой,
а с
RL
агентом.
Но
тут
важный
момент,
важно
помнить,
что
суррогат
может быть
неточен
за пределами
обучающего диапазона
и в целом
он является
приближенным
решением.
Поэтому
обучение
на таком
суррогате
это
некий
риск
того,
что
оптимизируется
не настоящая физика,
а какие-то
несуществующие
придуманные
суррогатом
закономерности.
Первая
пара
практических
нюансов
RL,
которым
нужно
заранее
низкая
эффективность
по данным
типичному
RL-агенту
нужны
тысячи
или миллионов
эпизодов,
уже многократно
говорилось,
чтобы научиться
хорошей политике.
И это
в прямой
вследствие
того,
что
агенты
учатся
методом
проб
ошибок,
а не
на
готовый
разметки.
И
ревордхакинг
в узлом
функции
наград,
когда агент
находит
формальную
лазейку
в награде
и оптимизирует
именно ее,
а не то
поведение,
которое имели
в виду
разработчики.
Итог,
у нас
формально
высокая
награда,
а по факту
не та
задача
решена.
И
практический
вывод,
что
дизайн
функции
наград
это
едва ли
не самая
сложная
часть
RL-проекта,
а не
какая-то
второстепенная
задача.
Секунду.
Продолжим.
И
еще
следующие
моменты,
нюансы.
Можно
столкнуться с
нестабильностью
обучения,
когда результат
RL часто
оказывается
сильно
чувствительным
к выбору
гиперпараметров
и даже
случайному
SID,
который
просто задает
генератору
случайных чисел
начальное
значение.
И
один и тот же
алгоритм
может зайти
по-разному
от запуска
к запуску.
разрыв
суррогат
симулятора
реальность.
Политика,
обученная
на суррогатной
модели,
может
не
перенестись
на настоящее
месторождение,
если суррогат
ошибается именно
в тех режимах,
которые
RL-агент
выбрал как
оптимальные.
И
безопасность
и ограничения.
Без явных
ограничений
RL-агент
в процессе
исследования
может
предложить
физически
недопустимое
или опасное
действие.
И
нужно
накладывать
ограничения
в саму
постановку
задачи,
а не
надеяться,
что
агент
сам
все
поймет.
И
переходим
к следующему
разделу
мультиагентные
системы.
Для
вашей
задачи
нужен
самый
важный
раздел,
потому
что
здесь
разберем
архитектурную
ошибку.
мультиагентная
система
это
несколько
автономных
агентов,
действующих
в общей
среде.
У каждого
свои собственные
наблюдения
и свои
собственные
действия,
но при этом
следующее
состояние
среды
и награда
каждого
отдельного
агента
зависит
от
совместного
действия
сразу
всех
агентов.
Формальная
математическая
рамка для
этого
называется
тахотическая
игра
Markov
Game.
Это
прямое
в общении
уже
известном
MDP,
на
случай
сразу
нескольких
игроков.
И вот
ключевое
отличие
от
одноагентного
RL,
которое мы
разбирали
в предыдущем
разделе.
Агенту
здесь нужно
учитывать
не только
динамику
самой
среды,
но еще
и поведение
других
агентов.
А это
поведение
может быть
кооперативным,
конкурентным
или вообще
заранее
неизвестным.
Разберем
сначала
спектр
возможных
архитектур
координации
между
агентами.
плюс
к базовой
архитектуре
добавляется
еще одна
ось,
кооперативная
постановка,
когда у всех
агентов
общая цель
конкурентная,
антагонистичная
или смешанная.
паргонаталья
три основных
парадигмы.
Централизованная
подход,
когда один
контроллер
видит
абсолютно
все
и сам
выбирает
совместные
действия
для всех
агентов
сразу.
Это
оптимально
с точки
зрения
теории,
не теряется
никакой
информации,
но требует
полной
связности
между
всеми
частями
системы
и очень
плохо
масштабируется
на большое
число
агентов,
пространство
местных
действий
растет
экспоненциально.
Дезентрализованный
подход,
когда агент
учится
и действует
опираясь
только на
свои
собственные
наблюдения,
это
дешево
и хорошо
масштабируется,
но агент
буквально
слеп,
потому что
делают
остальные.
И
это
прямой
путь
к проблемам.
Третий
промежуточный
вариант
CTD,
централизованное
обучение
и
централизованное
исполнение.
Сегодня
доминирующая
парадигма
мультиагентного
обучения
под креплением
и ее
логику
разберем
отдельно.
Теперь
такой
почему
интуитивно
привлекательная
идея
изначально
один агент
на каждую
скважину
на практике
почти гарантированно
упирается в стену.
Здесь
я сразу
оговорюсь,
прямая
формальная
связка
физики
полста
с терминологией
мультиагентного
обучения,
которую я сейчас
вложу.
Это мое
собственное
рассуждение
и синтез.
Непрямая
цитата.
Первая
причина
это
нестационарность.
С точки
зрения
одного
агента
среда
выглядит
нестационарной,
поскольку
все остальные
агенты
одновременно
меняют свою
стратегию
и цель
обучения
плывет.
Плюс
у нас есть
физическая
связность.
Это
скважины
в общем
власти
физически
связаны.
заказчик
добычи
одной
меняет
давление
у соседних,
локальное
партимальное
действие
одной
скважины
может
упустить
результат
другой.
Существуют
примеры,
где автор
явно
замечает,
что
одноагентный
RL
не справляется
с одновременной
оптимизацией
нескольких
скважин
именно потому,
что действие
одной
влияет
на результаты
других.
Важный
момент.
Агент
на каждую
скважину
не факт,
что
сработает.
Дальше.
Проблема
распределенного
вклада.
Это когда
общий
результат
вследствие
совместных
действий
многих
агентов
непонятно
какое
действие
какого
агента
у нас
будет
приводить
к хорошему
или плохому
исходу.
Проблема
ленивого
агента
или
при слабо
информативной
общей награде
агент
часто
может
спрятаться
за спиной
остальных
и не
внося
вообще
общего
вклада.
И
комбинаторный
взрыв.
У полностью
децентрализованной
системы
экспоненциально
растет
количество
связей
и
один
какой-то
большой
агент
на все
скважины
тоже
не очень
масштабируется.
полная
и полная
независимость
агентов
и полная
централизация
упираются
в свои
пределы
и нужен
некий
промежуточный
вариант
их
координации
между
собой.
И как раз
CTD
является
таким
вариантом.
с одной
стороны
у нас
есть
подход
в виде
когда
раскладывают
общую ценность
команды
на вклад
отдельных
агентов
что напрямую
решает
задачу
или
некий
общий
критик
который
обучающийся
на совместных
действиях
всех агентов
при этом
каждый агент
действует
по своей
локальной
политике.
И получается
что у нас
обучение
централизовано
доступ к общей
информации
состояние
действий
всех агентов
у нас есть
а при этом
исполнение
децентрализуется
и каждый агент
действует
только по
своим
локальным
наблюдениям.
Помимо
таких вот
подходов
есть другие
механизмы
координации
которые
стоит знать
есть
Team Reward
командная
награда
снимает
только часть
проблемы
но
создает
свою
это
ленивый
агент
а
индивидуальные
награды
рискуют
тем самым
эффектом
каждый
сам за себя.
Обучаем
коммуникации
между агентами
агенты
обменивают
сообщения
через общую
сеть
обучаются
end-to-end
а не
жестко
задаванным
протоколом
и некие
может быть даже
иерархические
структуры
координатор
менеджер
верхнего уровня
плюс
некие
локальные
агенты
исполнители
альтернативы
плоской схеме
когда просто
у нас есть
один
центральный
или
полностью
независимые
агенты.
Итоговый
слайд
главные
практические
правила
не берите
независимых
агентов
без механизма
координации
по умолчанию
один
агент
откажен
без общей
информации
почти гарантированно
отнесся на
мест
ценность
или
кредит
асин
варианты
которые стоит
рассмотреть
это общий
командный
сигнал
награды
value
decomposion
коммуникации
между агентами
иерархическая
структура
но
конкретный выбор
архитектуры
зависит от вашей
задачи
и остается за вами
здесь только
карта
вариантов
а не
готовый
рецепт
итого
что мы
разобрали
в введении
диплёринг
как
черный ящик
формализацию
претендный спуск
нелинейность
как разбивать выборки
перешли
к
рекуррентным сетям
и вниманием
современным
архитектурам
и
как вообще
работать
как
нервные сети
работают
с последовательностями
немножко поговорили
про интерпретируемость
attention map
attention layout
какие есть пределы
суррогатные модели
быстрая такая
аппроксимация
дорогого симулятора
поговорили про
экстраполяции
разобрали
RL
управление
как последовательное
принятие решения
и немножко
про
мультиагентные системы
почему агент на скважину
не масштабируется
без координации
далее у меня
есть еще
список литературы
презентацию
вам
думаю
перешлют
и
можно будет
с этим
работать
спасибо за внимание
я готов
ответить на вопросы
вы будете
писать их в чат
если какие-то есть
вопросы
вы
если
вопросов нет
то
еще раз спасибо за внимание
всем удачи
м